leute ganz wichtig bevor es losgeht
wollte ich noch eine sache sagen und
zwar ich bin so jemand falls sich auf
eine idee komme dann mache ich das
einfach erstmal und bedenklich dass das
vielleicht auch ein bisschen gefährlich
und vielleicht auch ein bisschen
unüberlegt ist also ich hab das ja dann
auch so durchgezogen ich habe die
ausgepackt und so weiter das werde jetzt
gleich alles sehen also es geht um eine
kettensäge habt ihr wahrscheinlich am
bildschirm gelesen das ist allerdings
kein spielzeug wie einen playstation
controller oder sonst was also da sollte
man wirklich vorsichtig mit sein
er hatte mir mein vater dabei nicht
geholfen hätte ich das video
wahrscheinlich gar nicht so umsetzen
können ich habe die auch am ende
getestet damit das wichtig war
allerdings habe ich die nicht so heftig
getestet wie ich das in meinem kopf mir
vorgestellt habe also ich bin jetzt
nicht hingegangen und habe irgendwas
durch gesägt mit dieser rutsch
kettensäge also vor allem anhängern von
euch macht das auf keinen fall nach und
jetzt würde ich sagen geht es los
schutzkleidung ist immer das wichtigste
die hatte ich zum beispiel auch nicht
und ich glaube man braucht auch ein
schein dafür wenn man es ihr sich auch
privaten grundstück macht keine ahnung
kenne ich mich nicht aus
auf jeden fall geht es los ich wünsche
euch viel spaß und nicht nach mir bitte
[Musik]
als gedacht von herzlich willkommen bei
dem ersten video aus dieser woche und
zwar stehe heute an ich war bis gestern
so mitbekommen habe ich habe mir das
ganz speziell ist überlegt jetzt gerade
zu weihnachten wo wahrscheinlich viele
noch ein paar coole geschenke suchen ja
gut ob das jetzt so passt weiß ich auch
nicht es gibt allerdings die nächsten
sieben tage jeden tag ein video zur alex
w risch woche also mir ist das irgendwie
so spontan eingefallen dass ich das doch
einfach mal eine woche durchziehen
könnte jeden tag ein neues video
meistens geht es halt um neue produkte
die ich halte aber diesmal wirklich
richtig geile produkte wir haben auch
direkt also ich hätte wirklich niemals
damit gerechnet dass es so was dort zu
kaufen gibt ja also selbst überall ein
paar kartons zu halten sind auch noch
brechen im auto habe ich auch noch
einige heute geht es eigentlich erst mal
um dieses dicke paket hier
bevor wir haben allerdings loslegen noch
mal wichtige info und zwar in jedem
video das jetzt in dieser woche kommt
hat jeder die chance vielleicht einmal
auf dieses produkt also wir können das
gewinnen ich wünsche euch dann nach
hause und die zweite sache was ich noch
dazu läge ist 100 euro schein damit
können die einkaufen was ihr wollt es
gibt halt dann in jedem video zu
gewinnen also einmal den 100 euro
gutschein und das produkt zürich weiss
dann zu euch nach hause das einzige was
sie dafür machen müsst schreibt einfach
irgendein kommentar abonnieren und ihr
könnt auch gern nach oben geben und dann
würde ich sagen
mal schauen wer dieses teile gewinnt ich
muss allerdings jetzt mal sagen ich bin
wirklich gespannt auf und wie es
funktioniert ich habe gestern schon mal
reingeguckt also ein bisschen
und ihr habt ja wahrscheinlich auch
schon am titel gelesen es ist eine
kettensäge
also ich hab dir gesehen und ich habe
sofort zugeschlagen das teil hat glaube
ich 77 dollar für mich gekostet check
immer gleich nochmal abgänger von diesem
dollar drin aber eigentlich natürlich
euro hier oben haben wir schon direkt
das sägeblatt weiß man dass so nennt ich
kenne mich natürlich auch nicht genau
aus und hier muss ich jetzt wirklich
sagen das ist echt schwer ja jetzt mal
raus
ok von der marke coaches war das so
ausspricht an die cracks um euch tut mir
leid wenn ich jetzt nicht so ganz in der
materie bin
[Musik]
die haben wir dann sterbe vor
aber jetzt geht es weiter mit dem motor
[Musik]
hier haben wir dann auch so ein behälter
wo vermutlich benzin rein kommt damit
das ding überhaupt angeht so der hat der
studie mal kurz an die seite haben wir
noch die ketten ja habe ich mich schon
gewundert wo die sind mann passt hier
drin ist oder einmal einen
schraubenzieher also alles halb werkzeug
um das ding zum laufen zu bringen bevor
wir damit allerdings jetzt weitermachen
würde ich sagen wir schauen sich erstmal
das produkt auf der website an die
bewertung und so weiter ihr könnt ja
jetzt wird sollte erstmal die die sich
jetzt fragen warum sehen deine haare
jetzt plötzlich so aus ich war
vorgestern meinem friseur und hab den
ersten part möchte jetzt ausgepackt habe
schon davor aufgenommen aber gut ist ja
kein problem
wir schauen uns jetzt erst mal zusammen
die kettensäge an die ich bestellt hat
ich habe keine ahnung wieso ist
neuerdings obwohl ich kettensägen gibt
habe ich vorher noch nie gesehen wurde
mir aber irgendwie überall angezeigt und
dann bin ich halt auf die idee gekommen
kommt bestellst du dir einfach mal um
status damit in die woche es gibt
wirklich viel auswahl hier gibt's sogar
eine 428 euro
ich habe moment wir schauen mal kurz
darauf genau diese kettensäge bestellt
jetzt sogar nur noch bei 65 eur 55 liegt
ich habe mit versand um die 80 oder 85
euro dafür bezahlen gehabt das modell ja
auch schon leid gesehen wie es wirklich
aussieht so sieht das ganze halt auf
bildern aus das ist alles dabei wir
haben hier gerade mal zwei bewertungen
und niemand hat wirklich einen text zu
verfassen das heißt das produkt wurde
anscheinend noch nicht oft gekauft ich
frage mich ernsthaft wer über wunsch
eine kettensäge kauft auf jeden fall
haben wir das modell pitschel tools lama
war konnte man auch nur hier in einer
farbe kaufen in orange falls ihr davon
habt dann könnt ihr mir das ja gerne in
die kommentare schreiben um was für
modell es sich da handelt ist das
irgendwann billig abklatsch aus china
keine ahnung jetzt habe ich gerade mal
hier den namen eingegeben der hier auch
steht und da findet man sogar einiges
also das gleiche modell gibt es
anscheinend auch auf ebay ist
wahrscheinlich dann einfach nur so ein
anbieter der das über möglichst viele
shops vertreiben will trotzdem habe ich
die hier über ersteigert und wir schauen
jetzt mal ob's funktioniert wie die
funktioniert und schöne grüße auch in
meinem vater der mir da einiges bei
geholfen hat ich glaube ich selber hätte
das niemals zum laufen bekommen ja
letztlich nur leute wirkungen zurück ich
habe das ding ist können wir eingepackt
das problem ist oder das heißt problem
sei nicht mein problem ich war als heute
spiel hast du meinen eltern dort ist es
etwas ländlicher da kann man sowas dann
auch mal ausprobieren war uns im garten
zum beispiel ich muss mich damit
allerdings in ruhe noch mal
auseinandersetzen weil man sollte weil
sowas natürlich nicht überstürzt muss
das sehr gefährlich deswegen ist mir
gerade aufgefallen
ich schicke natürlich nicht jemand von
euch diese hätten zwischen die pause
es sei denn ihr könnt mir vorweisen dass
sie hat über 18 seid und euch damit
vielleicht auskennt ansonsten würde ich
sagen stocken wir diesen ersten
gutschein auf 150 euro und lassen dann
die kettensäge prämiert also ich finde
dass meine eltern und ich würde sagen
dort sehen wir uns dann wieder minister
ich habe einen tiny koloss ich muss mich
noch mal kurz rein lesen viel
komplizierter als ich mir das
vorgestellt habe
[Musik]
leute so also werden dass dinge zusammen
gebaut das hat echt länger gedauert als
gedacht also ungefähr eine stunde diese
ganze beschreibung kann ich euch mal
kurz zeigen oder ist halt alles sehr
schlecht abgedruckt und alles auf
englisch also hatten wir auch schon mal
leichter zum glück nicht nur chinesisch
das gab es ja auch schon auf jeden fall
ist das jetzt fertig zusammengebaut das
einzige was jetzt noch fürs benzin damit
es angehen und deswegen muss ich jetzt
leider auch zur tankstelle fahren benzin
kaufen und dann probieren was einfach
mal hier kommen jetzt das ganze benzin
rein wir fahren zur tankstelle
mal sehen wie teuer es wird jetzt gleich
soweit ich weiss los das problem ist an
keiner einzigen tankstelle
ich habe jetzt drei abgefahren gab es
dieses öl was da rein
dann habe ich jetzt den kettensägen
experten gefragt und der meinte
normalerweise sollte da auch normales
benzin also super funktioniert das habe
ich jetzt gekauft muss ich jetzt wohl
noch mischen und dann schauen wir mal ob
das funktioniert ich will es hoffen
hier ist das benzin drin
jetzt kommt das will hier rein ja recht
haben oder das benzin öl gemisch
[Musik]
ja ich hatte jetzt gedacht das ist ein
bisschen leiser dass man das was sie
viel leichter bricht sie funktioniert
und das war eigentlich nur das was ich
wissen wollte warum
ja es ist sehr gefährlich also nicht
dann ist das nicht monetarisiert war das
video wenn ich den titel schreiben
geworden wegen kettensäge ich so richtig
gute leute das war's mit dem video geben
doch nach oben
vergesst nicht ich mach das nochmal in
ruhe in köln also aber auf jeden fall
noch kurz dranbleiben leute das war's
mit dem video nochmal ganz wichtig macht
das nicht nach und ich habe glaube ich
noch nicht gesagt oder ich weiß gar
nicht ihr könnt ihr jetzt auf jeden fall
könnt ihr ja in jedem video das jetzt
die nächsten tage kommt diesen 100 euro
erscheint und dann sicher das produkt
die kettensäge gewinnen bei dieser würde
ich jetzt sagen das schicke ich eher
ungern raus es sei denn ihr könnt mir
vor weise dass ihr euch wirklich gut
auskennt und sowas gebrauchen können
keine ahnung vorbei ja auch der zufall
über den gewinner entscheidet ansonsten
würde ich sagen dass ich dann in diesem
fall auf 150 euro aufstocker also wir
haben heute 950 euro scheint das einzige
was ihr machen müsst um dort
teilzunehmen kommentiert irgendwas
abonniert den kanal und die gewinner
werden dann am 25
dezember bekanntgegeben hier auf youtube
aber auf instagram 30 alex wie das war's
mit dem ersten video ich hoffe es hat
euch gefallen lassen
nach oben da wir sehen uns morgen wieder
19 uhr gibt es das nächste video haut
rein
und ja ich freue mich auf morgen ich
freue mich auf morgen einschalten